I plan to look at many great thinkers
over the course of this learning from
legend series lined up er Albert
Einstein Nikolai Tesla Galileo Fibonacci
and many others all these people had
huge impacts on their chosen fields and
the direction of mankind in general
what's interesting about da Vinci though
is that a lot of his research and many
of his inventions had no impact on the
scientific community or technological
progress but far from making him less
impressive that's in many ways what
makes him so fascinating Leonardo da
Vinci was a man possessed of an
indomitable curiosity that would lead
him to make pioneering discoveries in
countless fields from biology to
engineering to architecture to astronomy
and many more and much of this he did
for no other reason than to sate that
thirst for knowledge his discoveries
would go unpublished and his genius
would go unrecognized for hundreds of
years after his death he was the
prototypical Renaissance man and in some
ways the inventor of steampunk
creating technologies that seemed as
though they should never have existed in
his time rewinding a little Leonardo was
born Leonardo Di ser Piero da Vinci on
15th of April 1450 to in the Tuscan town
of Vincey his name literally means
Leonardo of Vincey as is now legend
Leonardo was the illegitimate son of the
wealthy Meza Piero througho see know the
Antonio
da Vinci as usual apologies for
butchering all these names and words and
a peasant girl Catarina de mio Lippe
meaning that he would stand to inherit
none of the family estate and nor would
he be able to continue his father's
business da Vinci is largely thought to
have been homosexual was considered
attractive and was in great physical
shape some suggests that the Vitruvian
Man is actually a self-portrait he was
outgoing confident and well liked which
helped him to overcome what would have
been social disadvantages at that time
there is some debate as to whether
Leonardo da Vinci was her left handed or
ambidextrous in fact though a recent
study by researchers from effete see
gallery in Florence suggests that he was
really ambidextrous in all likelihood
the Leonardo would have taught himself
to use his right hand over his dominant
left
and and that would have led to him
becoming ambidextrous other famous minds
such as Albert Einstein Benjamin
Franklin Nikolai Tesla and others are
also thought to have been ambidextrous
it's possible that this may even help to
thicken the corpus callosum the bridge
of neural fibers crossing the
longitudinal fissure between the left
and right hemispheres of the brain this
could improve whole brain thinking
potentially during his childhood he
reportedly spent a lot of time exploring
the countryside where he was inspired by
nature the flight of birds in particular
and the movement of water this time
spent observing nature is something else
that many great thinkers seem to have
had in common and the power of nature to
inspire is well documented unable to
join any of the prestigious guilds owing
to the nature of his birth Leonardo was
instead apprentice to the artist known
as ver ochio his workshop was considered
one of the finest in Florence and was
renowned for working in a variety of
mediums it was also responsible for many
engineering sketches of bridges and the
like for clients such as the powerful
medici family by the age of 20 leonardo
qualified as a master in the guild of
st. luke a guild of artists and medical
doctors his father later set him up with
his own workshop but he continued to
work closely with baroque EO while also
working on his own commissions such as
they never completed the adoration of
the Magi around 1478 a couple of years
after Leonardo closely evaded charges of
sodomy florence and naples almost went
to war and the men from da Vinci's guild
were tasked with designing weapons and
defenses to help defend the city a job
that da Vinci took a clear liking T by
this time Leonardo had already begun
keeping extremely detailed notes of his
ideas inventions and observations his
ideas included designs for machinery
such as water wheels and hoists and
studies in maths nature and biology over
15,000 pages of da Vinci's notes have
survived collected into works called
codices among his writings da Vinci
wrote numerous to-do lists these weren't
filled with the household chores like
taking out trash however but rather
included lists of experts whose brains
could pick get to the master of
arithmetic to show you how to square a
triangle for example as well as random
questions observations and areas for
further investigation particularly well
known as his notice
self reading described the tongue of the
woodpecker these notes are also
well-known for having been written
backwards
some say that this was a form of code
but in all likelihood it was simply a
result of da Vinci's preference for
writing with his left hand due to the
design of quills at the time it would
likely have been easier for him to write
that way
years later Leonardo would move to Milan
to secure work in the region da vinci
first made contact with the Duke of
Milan Ludovic esport sir describing
himself as a weapons engineer and
musician only mentioning and passing
that he could also paint to try and
curry favor he showed several weapons
designs to Fort Sir including his
now-famous tank or armoured vehicle this
was a weapons platform that would be
powered by the passengers themselves
allowing them to carry and operate far
greater artillery and it would be
covered in sloped Armour so as to
deflect enemy weaponry the design while
never actually created allegedly would
have worked safer one distinctive error
cogs inserted backward is since been
suggested that Leonardo actually
incorporated this error on purpose to
protect his invention during a time
before patents other weapons designed by
da Vinci included a 33 barreled quasi
machine gun that reduced the amount of
time required for firearms to be
reloaded and a scuba diving suit that
can be used to take out enemy ships from
beneath these designs show not only da
Vinci's engineering skills and fervent
imagination but also his understanding
of tactics and warfare these devices
solved common problems and created new
strategic possibilities unfortunately
for da Vinci sports er was far more
interested in his artistic talents than
his weapons designs commissioning him
first to paint a portrait of his wife
called lady with an ermine and then to
sculpt a 24 foot tall bronze horse which
in reality would likely have been
impossible for him to complete on his
own without studio but he winged it
anyways and after showing a prototype of
the horse da Vinci was accepted into the
royal court the Vinci would also work as
a theatre producer for sports er wowing
audiences with his technological
special-effects no doubt this experience
would further inform many of his later
inventions Sforza decided to go to war
prior to the completion of the horse
which fortunately got him off the hook
the metal resources were better used
elsewhere at this point during this time
Leonardo was commissioned to paint the
Last Supper which took him three years
to complete but
straights many of his studies in
mathematics physics human behavior and
the properties of light of course it's
gone on to become a seminal work of art
Leonardo would spend the further 17
years in sports as royal court and
eventually also kept himself busy
working on his own personal projects
among the most notable was his work on
cadavers which he kept quiet in order to
avoid another scandal or upset with the
Catholic Church his detailed sketches of
the human body today considered
revolutionary and include a
comprehensive and accurate depiction of
the heart with correct understanding of
the operation of his valves ventricles
and atriums he was also the first to
observe the s-shaped curvature of the
spine
curators at the Royal Collection Trust
said that had the works been published
they would have formed the most
influential works on the human body ever
produced that said his understanding of
the circulatory system was not perfect
and was limited by the knowledge and
technology of his time he believed for
instance that the muscles would consume
the blood they received nevertheless
many believe that these sketches are
among his most impressive works marrying
his curiosity scientific understanding
and beautiful illustrations another of
da Vinci's most famous works during this
time was the robot Knight commissioned
by sports of himself just as impressive
was the self-propelled cart which was
effectively programmable using
incredibly detailed mechanisms to enable
preset routes another of da Vinci's
creations from this time is the viola
organist er an organ that emulated a
string instrument like a modern
synthesizer when the Sportster family
lost its power and the French invaded da
Vinci would return to Florence in 1500
at the ripe age of 50 here he would go
on to develop a rivalry with young
upstart painter Michelangelo during this
time he also took another stab at
military design working for the ruthless
Cesare Borgia he became the chief
general engineer supervising the
construction of towers as well as
creating bird's-eye view maps of cities
which were as with much of da Vinci's
work well ahead of their time turned out
though that bourgeois was a little too
ruthless for da Vinci who was at heart a
pacifist and so he built a high-tech
suit of armor and began the process of
confiscating all of his misappropriated
weaponry sorry wrong guy da Vinci fled
boggers employ in the dead of night
before returning to Florence
here living on the money he earns from
his work for Borger he would paint the
Mona Lisa as a personal passion project
he also spent much of his time building
wings as he do as is extremely well
documented flight was to Vinci's
absolute passion and he spent untold
amounts of time designing incredible
flying machines and studying the flight
of birds some of his earliest notes
include designs for planes and
helicopters one of these early attempts
was the aerial screw which effectively
wound itself into the air like a
helicopter all of this design likely
wouldn't have worked it demonstrated a
keen understanding of lift while he
never built a working flying machine his
closest design was the ornithopter which
was a human powered flying machine that
utilized huge wings you empowered
ornithopters have eventually been
constructed demonstrating that the idea
was at least sound in theory so he was
close da Vinci lived out his family is
in France invited as he was by King
Francis the first and given the use of
his manor house cross Luke
Leonardo suffered a stroke at the age of
65 that robbed him of the use of one arm
and he died in 1519 leaving behind the
Mona Lisa and his many work books
looking back at da Vinci's legacy what's
most striking is the sheer breadth of
his studies we haven't even discussed
the ways in which his art was actually
informed by mathematics how he would
utilize golden ratios in the Fibonacci
sequence to make his imagery more
aesthetically pleasing or how he would
play with perspective and lighting
drawing from his own studies and
experience as a theater producer the
Vitruvian Man is perhaps the perfect
example of this marriage of art maths
and science being not only highly
accurate depiction of the human form but
also a kind of thought experiment
showing how that form could
hypothetically be used to solve an
impossible maths problem squaring a
circle in case you hadn't noticed the
Vitruvian Man has also inspired my own
lego da Vinci also designed dams and
submarines experimented with geometry
and made many fascinating observations
in the fields of astronomy geography and
more he theorized on the nature of
tectonic plates and suggested that the
dark spots on the moon couldn't have
been vapour as they wouldn't remain
static if that were the case he
researched biology botany architecture
and countless other fields all of this
was self directed driven by pure passion
for knowledge rarely was he motivated by
money or fame and this multi-discipline
in nature was not a limitation but in
fact one of his greatest strengths his
ability to draw on this foot feels like
art a science and maths gave him a
unique perspective that others lacked
never did he let his lack of
qualifications or formal training stand
in his way and this is what we can all
learn from da Vinci to follow our
interests and to never assume that we
can't contribute valuable ideas and
works individuals can still make a
difference even if it doesn't lead to a
big career change that doesn't mean you
shouldn't pursue what fascinates you or
conduct your own experiments there are a
few feelings more exciting than coming
up with a truly unique idea or invention
or discovering something exciting for
the first time and with the tools
available to us today tools for learning
and creating our individual potential is
limitless
imagine if da Vinci had access to the
Internet or a 3d printer what da Vinci
did have was relentless optimism and
self belief being convinced that someday
you'd be able to conquer gravity and
master flight what could be more
inspiring than that imagine if da Vinci
eventually had built his own working
ornithopter and had taken to the skies
on the power of his imagination alone so
I hope you found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like please comment down below
and let me know what you think has da
Vinci inspired you in any way what
things are you researching or
experimenting on or building right now
I've got lots more like this on the way
of course the next video is going to be
the part 2 of the Nightwing training
however I'm also going to be starting a
new polymath series inspired by da Vinci
where I'm going to be looking into all
kinds of different topics that we can
teach ourselves that's going to include
things like programming which lots of
people have asked for hacking
neuroscience Anatomy and maybe in the
future things like electronics
engineering or even calculus these are
all things that I'm learning and that
I'd like to share with you guys - if
that sounds something that you're
interested in then let me know down
below as always thanks a ton for
watching guys and I'll see you next time
bye for now